.
Er kletterte ungesichert
in die steilsten Wände.
Er balancierte
gefährlich nah am Abgrund.
Der Bergsteiger Ueli Steck.
Die meisten, die mich zum
ersten Mal sehen, und nicht wissen,
was dahinter steckt, denken:
"Der Steck, der spinnt."
Der Mensch braucht Herausforderungen
und Abenteuer,
das macht mein Leben
auch lebenswert.
Er war wohl der Beste,
mit dem ich je geklettert bin.
Wie er die Wände hinaufrannte ...
Fitter als alle anderen.
Ueli Steck schaffte an den grössten
Nordwänden Geschwindigkeitsrekorde.
Vor drei Jahren stürzte er
im Himalaya 1'000 m in die Tiefe
und starb.
Es ist ein schmaler Grat
zwischen Überleben und Sterben,
wenn man an die Grenzen geht.
Weshalb suchen Menschen ihre Grenzen?
Und warum gehen sie
so hohe Risiken ein?
Was hat Ueli Steck angetrieben?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Kathmandu, Nepal.
Am Tag des Unfalls war er
zu ihm unterwegs, Robert Bösch.
Der Fotograf
war nach Kathmandu gekommen,
um Ueli Stecks Expedition am Everest
fotografisch zu dokumentieren.
Stattdessen erhielt er
hier in Kathmandu
die Nachricht
vom Tod seines Freundes.
Das war schon ein grausamer Moment.
Gleichzeitig muss ich rückblickend
sagen: Ich war extrem froh,
dass ich hier drüben war
in dieser Zeit.
Ich war froh, dass ich das nicht
in der Schweiz erleben musste.
Ich bin eigentlich dankbar,
dass ich hier war.
Ich erinnere mich noch genau,
als wir uns am Flughafen trafen
und du sagtest: "Ich habe sehr
schlechte Nachrichten."
Dendi Sherpa,
ein Freund von Ueli in Nepal,
überbrachte Robert Bösch
damals die Todesnachricht.
Du bekamst die Nachricht 5 Min.,
bevor ich ankam.
Ja. Ich erhielt die Information
gerade vor deiner Landung,
vielleicht eine halbe Stunde vorher.
So ein unglaublicher Moment.
Eigentlich
begreift man es erst so richtig,
wenn sich dieser ganze Staub
wieder legt,
und der Alltag weitergeht.
Und dann merkst du plötzlich:
Jetzt hätte ich Ueli angerufen,
gefragt,
ob er Zeit hat zum Klettern.
Im gleichen Moment weisst du,
dass er nicht mehr da ist.
Aber dann merkst du,
wo er dir überall fehlt.
Hier hat er für sich
ein Gewehr herausgeschnitten.
Ja, genau.
- Oder?
In Egerkingen.
- Das ist in Egerkingen?
Wie hiess das dort?
Das Säckli,
das er selbst genäht hat,
die Hose, die ich ihm genäht habe.
Das ist irgendwo an einem Ort,
wo er Eisklettern war.
Er ist einfach immer noch hier.
Es ist einfach noch zu nah.
Aber wir können jetzt darüber reden,
ohne dass gleich die Tränen kommen.
Schau, das ist die gleiche,
das ist auch 1995.
Das ist Eis.
- Das ist Eis, ja.
Da ist er auch einmal
runtergefallen, beim Eisklettern.
Als er mit 16 zum ersten Mal
durch die Eigernordwand ging,
schliefen wir nicht wahnsinnig gut.
Aber wir haben gesagt:
"Es ist sein Leben."
Wir wollten unser Leben nicht
durch die Angst kaputt machen.
Es kann ja überall etwas passieren.
Im Hinterkopf hat man es,
aber wenn es passiert,
ist es eine Katastrophe -
für alle Eltern.
Es ist einfach so, wenn ein Mensch
stirbt, ist es einfach etwas ...
Dabei ist es ja das Natürlichste auf
der Welt. Jeder muss einmal gehen.
* Minimalistische,
melancholische Klänge *
Der Fotograf Robert Bösch
ist selber Bergsteiger.
Oft war er zusammen mit Ueli
hier in Nepal.
Es ist 2019,
zwei Jahre nach Ueli Stecks Tod,
als wir ihn in Kathmandu treffen.
Wir wollen nochmals in das Leben
seines Freundes eintauchen.
Verstehen, warum er immer wieder
die Herausforderung suchte.
Fototermin für einen guten Zweck.
Can you go behind?
Robert Bösch fotografiert
für ein Schweizer Hilfswerk.
You look great.
Big smile. No smile.
Etwas weiter runter, und dann
gehst du nochmals etwas hoch!
Er dokumentierte die Karriere
von Ueli Steck von Anfang an.
Pickel einschlagen,
noch etwas höher.
Ich erinnere mich,
einmal filmten wir am Eigergipfel.
Es war -20 °C
und hatte fast 100 km/h Wind.
Wir waren beide restlos am Limit.
Das funktioniert nur noch.
Da gibt es kein "Mach das
noch einmal" oder sowas.
Ich habe die Finger
nicht mehr gespürt,
musste schauen, ob ich überhaupt
auslöse, ich spürte es nicht.
Er hatte weisse Flecken im Gesicht.
Wenn da jeder den anderen
noch hätte sichern müssen,
hätten wir das vergessen können.
Das ging nur, weil wir so schnell
waren -  und dann wieder weg.
Genau solche Erlebnisse
verbinden dann auch,
und geben der Freundschaft
eine gewisse Tiefe,
wenn man auch mal unangenehme
Situationen zusammen erlebt.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Ueli Steck, wie man ihn kannte.
Allein und ohne sicherndes Seil
in einer riesigen Wand.
Wenn ich an so einer Wand bin,
bin ich zu 100 % überzeugt,
dass ich am Abend wieder daheim bin.
Die Möglichkeit eines Absturzes
existiert in dem Moment nicht mehr.
Sie existiert im Vorfeld, da musst
du das ganz klar analysieren.
"Ist das möglich?"
"Ist es nicht zu schwer,
ist es nicht zu gefährlich?"
Da bist du dir ganz klar bewusst,
in was für eine Situation
du dich hinein manövrierst.
Ich glaube, es ist da drüben.
David Göttler,
deutscher Profibergsteiger,
kannte Ueli Steck sehr gut.
Hallo, alles gut?
- Ja, super. Alles gut geklappt.
Willkommen in Kathmandu.
Du bist ja auch nicht
zum ersten Mal hier.
Genau, das erste Mal
war ich hier mit dem Ueli.
Das ist dein Zimmer, ich habe
jetzt natürlich das grosse genommen.
Du, mir ist es total Wurscht.
Ich war im Basislager Shishapangma
damals, und es war genau der Ort,
an dem ich ein Jahr zuvor
mit Ueli war.
Und dann kam die Nachricht,
dass Ueli ums Leben kam am Nuptse.
Es riss mir den Boden
unter den Füssen weg.
Ich begann zu weinen, war ...
... quasi aufgelöst.
Aber man befindet sich dann
zuerst in so einem Vakuum.
Man begreift es nicht.
Total surreal.
Trotz des Todes seines Freundes
macht David Göttler weiter
mit dem Bergsteigen.
Schon in wenigen Tagen
will er Richtung Everest aufbrechen.
Für ihn war Ueli Steck
absolut einzigartig.
Dieses Commitment, quasi
in diese Ausgesetztheit zu gehen,
mit so einer Konsequenz,
mit so einem Minimalismus
an Sicherheitsnetzen,
die greifen,
wenn etwas ausserplanmässig läuft,
das war für mich
einfach das Aussergewöhnliche
an dieser Unternehmung.
Kurz vor dem Aufbruch
ins Everest-Gebiet:
Wieder passiert
ein tragischer Bergunfall.
Es ist fürchterlich.
Drei junge Profi-Bergsteiger sind
in einer Lawine ums Leben gekommen.
Es waren Könner, wie Ueli.
Bergsteigen
fordert das Schicksal heraus.
Und ist immer
ein Hoffen auf gutes Gelingen.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Robert Bösch und David Göttler
planen,
gemeinsam Richtung Everest zu reisen.
Hallo. Gleich gefunden.
Billi Bierling ist Chronistin
des Achttausender-Bergsteigens.
Ein Eintrag
in ihre Himalaya-Datenbank
gehört für Alpinisten
wie David Göttler
zum Ritual vor einer Expedition.
Es wird auch festgehalten,
wer mit wem unterwegs ist.
David und Ueli,
die haben sich wirklich gefunden.
Ich weiss es noch,
ich war mit Ueli Abendessen,
bevor er vor zwei Jahren
zum Everest ging.
Wir waren essen, unterhielten uns
und ich sagte zu Ueli:
"Ich freue mich so, dass es mit dir
und David so gut klappt."
Und da hatte er wirklich
so ein Strahlen in den Augen.
Er sagte: "Ja, Billi, endlich
habe ich jemanden gefunden,
der die genau gleiche Ethik oder
die Trainingsweise hat wie ich."
Gehst du vorher
noch auf einen anderen Berg?
Nee.
- Direkt, also.
Keine Sherpas, keine anderen Berge.
Wann kommst du ungefähr
im Basislager an?
Ich bin auch ganz wenig
im Basislager.
Ich geh immer runter.
Manchmal überrascht es mich selbst,
dass ich denke:
"Krass, wie kann es sein,
dass drei Freunde ums Leben kamen,
und ich trotzdem motiviert bin,
auf den Everest zu gehen,
mich wirklich darauf freue?"
Diese zwei Gefühls-Extreme,
die in einem drin sind.
Ich weiss nicht, warum das so ist.
Ein Selbstschutz?
Kann sein, wir Bergsteiger
sind sicher saugut
im Verdrängen von
solchen Ereignissen.
* Tibetische Musik *
Gehst du auch nach Lukla?
- Ja, ich bin dein Pilot.
Echt? Das ist gut.
Vom Flughafen Kathmandu aus
geht es in einem einstündigen Flug
mit dem Helikopter ins Khumbu,
das Gebiet um den Everest.
* Treibende Musik *
Lukla, ein Gebirgsflughafen
auf 2'800 m Höhe.
Alle Nepal-Reisenden kennen ihn.
Er gilt als
der gefährlichste Flughafen der Welt.
Wenn man sieht, wo die hier
landen müssen in den Bergen,
die Landebahn geht steil bergauf,
ist super kurz
und das ist halt berühmt-berüchtigt
für irgendwelche Unfälle.
Und jetzt gerade letzte Woche kam
hier beim Start, das sieht man noch,
ein Flieger von der Landebahn ab.
David Göttler war oft mit Ueli Steck
hier im Everest-Gebiet
zum Trainieren.
Und auch Robert Bösch
war früher als Bergsteiger
hier an den Achttausendern.
Ein Bild, das mir von Ueli
so hängen geblieben ist:
Sobald wir angefangen haben,
uns zu bewegen,
sobald er in Bewegung war,
laufend oder am Berg,
dann war es wie ein Schalter,
der bei ihm umgelegt worden ist,
dann war er voll in seinem Element.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, beim
ersten Mal war ich brutal nervös:
Er will laufen - laufen, wie laufen?
Ist es wirklich laufen-laufen
oder schnell gehen?
Es gibt ja viele solche Abstufungen.
25 km, 2'000 Höhenmeter.
David Göttler filmt die Reisen
mit Steck für seine Vorträge.
Also ich spüre die Höhe
von fast 5'000 m.
Wenn es steiler wird,
wie hier hinauf zur Lodge.
* Er keucht hörbar. *
Hi. Where did you come from today?
- From Namche.
Namaste. David.
- Lopsang.
Ueli Steck kehrte immer
an den gleichen Orten ein.
So entstanden viele Freundschaften.
Yesterday no flight,
today no flights.
Er macht mich fertig.
6 Std, 36 Min. von Chukung.
- Heute?
Zwei Pässe. Ja.
Darum sind wir hungrig.
Rennen, ja.
Chukhung, Kongma La, Cho-La-Pass.
Hierher.
Jetzt retour?
Jetzt Renjo La, Namche.
- Wow. Viel Glück.
Ich habe immer gesagt:
"Das sieht lahm aus auf den Bildern,
nur mit einem Trekkingstock."
"Nimm doch einen Pickel." Ich
wusste, er braucht keinen Pickel.
Ich riet ihm das nicht zur Sicher-
heit, sondern für das Bildmaterial.
Und er so:
"Nein, das brauche ich nicht."
"Und wenn das Bildmaterial
nicht passt, ist es auch egal."
In dieser Hinsicht war er stur.
Du brauchst einfach schnelle Schuhe,
dann reichen Stöcke.
Uh, hoppla und tschüss.
Komm, wir gehen hoch!
Absteigen soll Niklas.
Nein, Max, er soll doch runter.
Aufgewachsen
ist Ueli Steck im Emmental.
Seine Eltern leben heute noch hier.
Wie auch ein Bruder
mit seiner Familie.
Ueli war der Jüngste
von drei Brüdern.
Ein Windspiel. Er konnte nie ruhig
sein. Es musste immer etwas laufen.
Er musste immer etwas machen,
er war ein Lebendiger.
Wir hatten hier, wo sie aufgewachsen
sind, auch die Gelegenheit,
die Kinder hinaus zu lassen,
das war ideal.
Das war schon so.
Dass sie nicht immer
nur in der Stube waren.
Wir unternahmen auch viel mit ihnen.
Draussen, im Wald ...
Ich kann's selber.
- Du kannst es selber.
Trinkt mal etwas.
Hast du ausgetrunken?
Die beiden Brüder von Ueli
haben als Kinder Eishockey gespielt.
Ueli gefiel das nicht.
Er wollte klettern. Ich verstand
nicht ganz, wieso Klettern.
Da hat er mir erklärt:
"Weisst du, Vater,
beim Klettern ist es einfach."
"Wenn man hochkommt, ist man gut,
wenn man nicht hochkommt,
muss man üben, bis man oben ist."
"Da ist nicht der Trainer schuld
oder ein anderer."
Das hat er mir in der vierten Klasse
so gesagt.
Und ich stand da.
Und sagte: "Also gut."
Aber ich hatte ja
keine Ahnung von Klettern.
Ich hatte einen Kollegen,
den Morgenthaler Fritz,
der ab und zu kletterte.
Wir machten dann den Dülfersitz
und ich ging mit ihm Abseilen -
nicht Klettern, Abseilen.
Und dann haben wir ihn
einfach dort unterstützt.
Für uns war es ... Nicht, Niklas.
Für uns war immer klar,
dass etwas gemacht wird, aber etwas.
Und das wird dann durchgezogen.
Man beginnt nicht einfach, etwas zu
machen, und wenn man Beissen muss,
hört man einfach wieder auf.
Aber Ueli
war schon der Ehrgeizigste.
Wir mussten immer damit rechnen,
dass etwas passiert,
aber man kann es dann doch fast
nicht glauben, wenn es so weit ist.
Das hätte nicht sein müssen.
Im Nachhinein kann man sagen,
man hätte es besser verboten.
Aber er war als Bergsteiger
weniger verletzt
als Bruno, der Eishockey spielte.
Ueli war immer topfit.
Er hat sein Leben gelebt und wir als
Eltern haben unsere Pflicht getan.
Es ist jetzt einfach so.
Manchmal kann man gut damit umgehen
und dann gibt es Situationen,
in denen man
nicht darüber reden kann.
Z.B. Klettern oder so etwas im
Fernsehen schauen, das geht nicht.
Das ist einfach noch tabu.
Das ist wirklich
einfach noch zu nah.
Darum haben wir auch
einen Platz für uns,
von wo aus wir in die Berge sehen,
da können wir hingehen,
eine Kerze anzünden
und dann geht's jeweils wieder.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Damit wurde Ueli Steck weltberühmt.
Mit seinen Geschwindigkeitsrekorden
in der Eigernordwand.
Die ganze Eigernordwand
schaffte er 2007
in unglaublichen 3 Std. und 54 Min.
Doch das war erst der Anfang.
Nach einer Woche oder zwei
hatte ich ein komisches Gefühl.
Es ist zwar schon ein schönes Gefühl
und alle sagen:
"Wahnsinnig, der Steck klettert
unter 4 Std. die Eigernordwand."
Das ist etwas Neues.
Aber für mich
kam ein komisches Gefühl:
Ich dachte:
"Da bin ich nicht schön geklettert,
da habe ich mich seltsam verhalten,
diese Stelle könnte ich doch
viel lockerer klettern."
"Und dort war ich nicht optimal
in der Spur."
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
das ist nicht mein Limit.
Und so geht er ein Jahr darauf
nochmals.
Für den zweiten Versuch
ist er noch besser vorbereitet.
Er trainierte noch härter als vorher.
Im Innern bin ich leistungs-
orientiert, das gebe ich zu,
und ich definiere mich
sehr stark über meine Leistung.
Je mehr du in etwas investierst,
desto mehr Wert hat es.
Wenn etwas beim ersten Mal
einfach so gelingt,
hat es keinen Wert für mich.
Das hat mich gestört
und war der Punkt,
warum ich nochmals
einen Rekord machen wollte.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Diesmal ist er mehr als 1 Std.
schneller: 2 Std. und 47 Min.
* Keuchen *
Keine Zeitung, die nicht über ihn
und seine Rekorde geschrieben hätte.
Er hat sich nie verbogen,
war immer authentisch.
Er ging mit allen Leuten gleich um,
hat nie abgehoben.
Was Leute an ihm schätzten:
Er erzählte oft erst von Projekten,
wenn er sie geschafft hatte,
kündigte sie vorher nicht gross an.
Er brachte zuerst die Leistung,
dann hat man darüber geredet.
Das ist eine Eigenschaft, die die
Leute in der Schweiz auch schätzen.
Bruno Steck führte
für seinen Bruder die Geschäfte,
als dieser immer berühmter wurde.
Daneben hat er eine Immobilienfirma.
Ueli lebte sehr, sehr sparsam,
und hat den Räppler
drei-, viermal umgedreht,
bevor er ihn ausgegeben hat.
Als es ihm später besser ging,
war er sehr grosszügig.
Und er leistete es sich auch mal,
1. Klasse statt Business Class
zu fliegen.
Und von den Einnahmen her
machten die ganzen Vorträge
sicher einen grossen Teil aus,
die er für verschiedene
Organisationen halten konnte,
und zum anderen auch die Sponsoren,
die ihn teils die ganze Karriere
über begleitet haben.
Die Speed-Rekorde am Eiger
machten Ueli Steck schnell zu einem
der berühmtesten Bergsteiger
und einem gefragten Vortragsreisenden
und Interviewpartner.
(Frau)
What if we just return then and ...
Viele klettern gefährlicher
mit einem Partner als ich allein.
Warum?
Weil ich mich
auf einem anderen Level bewege.
Ich bereite mich minutiös vor,
bevor ich etwas mache.
Ich bin Schweizer,
mache alles Schritt um Schritt.
Seine Sponsoren
konnte er sich aussuchen.
Mich interessieren nur Sachen,
die mich sportlich interessieren.
Dann überlege ich mir,
kann man das vermarkten oder nicht.
Mache ich das für mich,
kann ich mir das leisten?
Das ist jetzt etwas Zusätzliches,
aber keine grosse Geschichte.
Oder muss ich mal wieder ...
Ein gewisser Leistungsausweis muss
da sein gegenüber einem Sponsor.
Ich mache nicht nur einfach etwas
für schöne Fotos.
Das interessiert mich
schlicht nicht,
und zum Glück
habe ich es auch nicht nötig.
Du bist spät dran.
Ich habe schon Anfragen für 2011.
Aber Dezember
ist in einem halben Jahr.
Ja, das ist voll.
Ich bin schon gebucht für 2011.
Schade.
- Schreib eine Mail!
In Moskau fragen alle:
"Wann kommt Ueli endlich zu uns?"
Ich komme gerne,
wenn du flexibel bist,
finde doch ein Datum
für nächstes Jahr.
Profi kann jeder werden,
die Frage ist nur,
wie viel bin ich bereit zu tun,
und auf wie viel bin ich bereit,
zu verzichten.
Von Ueli musste man nie verlangen,
dass er an einem Geburtstag oder
an einem Familienfest dabei ist,
aber das war man sich bewusst:
Wenn er irgendwo war, kam er nicht.
Das muss man akzeptieren.
Das andere ist sein
Trainingsfleiss und Trainingswille.
Auch wenn es die Öffentlichkeit
nicht sieht, um 5 Uhr aufzustehen.
Und 2 Std. im Regen rumrennen,
ohne dass es jemand sieht.
Solche Dinge.
Die Selbstdisziplin,
die er hatte, war riesig.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Es blieb nicht beim Speed-Rekord
am Eiger.
Er wollte die schnellste Zeit an
allen grossen Nordwänden der Alpen.
An der Grandes Jorasses im
Mont-Blanc-Gebiet und am Matterhorn.
Jeeh!
Du musst zuerst ...
Ich wollte zwei.
- Willst du beide mitnehmen?
Ja.
- Gut.
Langsam, Achtung!
Warte, Tobias!
Ihr könnt schon rein.
- Nimmst du deine Sachen?
Er muss auf Mama warten.
Also, gehen wir!
Man kann das nicht nachvollziehen,
wenn man es nicht selber erlebt hat.
Ich möchte mir nicht vorstellen,
was passiert,
wenn ich eines meiner Kinder
verliere.
Das bricht einem das Herz.
Daran nagt man wohl ein Leben lang.
Eishockey gehört nach wie vor
zum Leben von Bruno Steck.
Grossvater! Hilf mir!
Er war 15 Jahre lang Profi,
mit dem ZSC sogar Schweizer Meister.
Man braucht auch Glück im Leben,
das hatte ich sicher.
Das Wichtigste ist nebst Talent
Freude an dem was du machst.
Wenn du Freude hast, hast du Erfolg,
ganz egal, was du machst.
Heute ist er Trainer
zu Hause im EHC Burgdorf.
Ehrgeiz liegt in der Familie.
Ueli war nicht der einzige,
der zielstrebig
auf einen Erfolg hin arbeitete.
Gut, super, hey!
Er hat als Kind schon
überdimensioniert trainiert
und nicht eben viel
dem Zufall überlassen.
Ich weiss nicht, woher er das hatte.
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Wenn er etwas im Kopf hatte,
konnte man es ihm nicht nehmen.
Ja, das ist ...
Bruno war ähnlich,
er war als Eishockeyspieler
nie als Talent anerkannt,
zuletzt hat er aber doch
in der Nationalliga A gespielt.
Es war nur Kopfsache,
weil er das einfach wollte.
Der älteste Sohn
mit den Modellfliegern,
da ist er jetzt noch dabei,
und da war er immer voll dabei.
Er wurde da ja Schweizer Meister.
Das ist eine Kopfsache.
Schau!
Zurück in Lukla, in Nepal.
Robert Bösch und David Göttler
warten auf den Weitertransport.
Der Pilot Maurizio Folini war ein
weiterer Weggefährte von Ueli Steck.
Normalerweise arbeitet
Maurizio Folini im Engadin,
hilft aber während der Bergsteiger-
saison in Nepal aus.
* Tragende Klänge *
Ich habe Ueli
in Nepal kennengelernt.
Dann haben wir uns
auch in der Schweiz getroffen
für kleinere Projekte.
In diesem Jahr wollten wir
unsere ersten gemeinsamen
Bergsteigerprojekte machen.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut
und war etwas nervös,
mit einem so starken Bergsteiger
unterwegs sein zu können.
Das Everest-Basecamp auf 5'400 m.
Es ist April und die ersten Everest-
Expeditionen sind schon da.
Maurizio Folini
ist hier eine Institution.
Er war der Erste, dem eine Rettung
auf 7'800 m Höhe gelang.
Auch am Todestag von Ueli Steck
war er im Einsatz.
Ich war an jenem Tag in Namche,
am trainieren, mich akklimatisieren.
Ich weiss noch, es kam eine Meldung,
also die Basis rief mich an,
ich müsse mich parat machen.
Ich wusste einfach,
etwas am Everest.
Mehr Details hatte ich nicht.
Dann machten wir uns bereit,
mit Lakpa Nurbu
als Rettungsspezialist,
um eine Longline-Rettung zu machen.
Als er kam, sagte er mir,
es handelt sich um Ueli Steck.
Erst dann wusste ich es.
Dann war ich schockiert
für einen kurzen Moment,
aber dann habe ich mich konzentriert
auf meinen Job, und der war,
die Rettung durchführen.
Er fliegt mit uns nochmals hoch,
dorthin, wo er seinen toten Freund
bergen musste.
Am Nuptse, zuhinterst
am riesigen Khumbu-Gletscher.
Everest, Lhotse und Nuptse
bilden hier ein Hufeisen,
dessen Überschreitung
im Höhenbergsteigen
als eines der letzten
ungelösten Probleme gilt.
Hier oben ist er abgestürzt,
zuunterst ist er gewesen.
Er fiel natürlich mehr als 1'000 m
das Loch ab über das ganze Gelände.
Ihn dort unten auf dem Gletscher
zu holen war gar nicht schön.
Jetzt, da ich
die Absturzstelle nochmals sehe,
kommen wieder die Emotionen hoch.
Wir sind auf 7'000 m, so hoch hinauf
können nur wenige fliegen.
Das Lager 2 auf 6'400 m, von hier aus
war damals Ueli Steck gestartet.
Allein. War es zu viel Risiko?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Ueli
sein Leben mehr riskiert hat
als andere Menschen.
Er hat das gemacht,
wofür er auch trainiert hat.
Ich kann das, was Ueli machte,
mit meinem Job vergleichen:
In der Fliegerei bringe ich
Pilot und Maschine auch ans Limit,
wie es Ueli im Bergsteigen
auch machte.
Deswegen
sind wir keine Selbstmörder.
Wir leben einfach so intensiv
unser Leben, wie es für uns passt.
Namche Bazar, der Ausgangspunkt
für alle Everest-Trekkings.
Nach dem Helikopterflug
treffen sich hier die drei
Weggefährten von Ueli Steck.
Und, wie war's?
- Ja, gut.
Etwas hoch oben?
Nicht gerade so hoch.
Bis ca. 7'000 m.
Z.B. die Nuptse-Flanke,
wo Ueli abgestürzt ist,
dort war es blank, oben,
aber der Everest sieht gut aus.
Wie war es damals, nach dem Absturz
von Ueli, war es da blank?
Nein, gut eingeschneit. Ja.
Gefunden haben wir ihn hier,
unter dem Serac, dem grossen Fels.
Da unten war er.
Wer hat ihn eigentlich
als Erster gefunden?
Weisst du das noch?
Alarmiert haben Leute im Camp 2.
Okay.
Sie haben ihn beobachtet
beim Aufstieg.
Ob sie seinen Absturz gesehen haben,
weiss ich nicht.
Aber der Alarm kam vom Camp 2.
Im ersten Alarm, den ich bekam,
hiess es, dass zwei ...
Dass er mit ... äh ...
mit dem Franzosen.- Ah, Yannick.
Genau.
- Aber Yannick ist dann ...
Yannick hatte ihn
nur ein Stück begleitet.
Aber am Anfang hiess es,
beide seien abgestürzt.
Was sicher klar ist: Es war keine
Tour, die für ihn am Limit war.
Und die andere Überlegung
stimmt auch,
es passieren viele Unfälle
beim Bergstiegen dann,
wenn man nicht
am absoluten Limit ist.
Man hat am meisten Respekt,
wenn man weiss, man geht ans Limit,
aber oft oder meistens
passiert dann nichts.
Wir hatten hier unser Lager,
da kommt man aber nicht rüber.
Da fällst du nicht
am Anfang hier runter.
Er muss weit oben gewesen sein,
weil man ihn da unten gefunden hat.
* Minimalistische,
melancholische Klänge *
Ueli Steck war bereits berühmt in
Europa, aber noch nicht in Amerika.
Er reiste deshalb
für ein Kletter-Projekt
in den Yosemite-Nationalpark
in Kalifornien.
Als europäischer Bergsteiger,
da kannst du Eiger oder Matterhorn
klettern, man nimmt es zwar wahr,
aber wenn du
im Yosemite etwas machst,
dann wird es auch honoriert
und sie haben einen Bezug dazu
und darum ist es auch sehr wichtig.
Die bekannteste Route am Granitturm
El Capitan ist die Nose.
2010 wollte Ueli Steck auch hier
einen Speed-Rekord versuchen.
Zusammen mit Alex Honnold, dem heute
wohl berühmtesten Kletterer der Welt.
Als ich Ueli im Yosemite traf, war
ich viel jünger, hatte kein Geld.
Ueli war bereits so etwas wie eine
Legende. Bekannt und respektiert.
Ich war beeindruckt,
fand es toll, mit jemandem
seines Kalibers zu klettern.
Er war inspirierend.
So hart und seriös wie er
trainierte sonst niemand.
Ich dachte, wahrscheinlich
sollte ich auch härter trainieren.
I'm up, away, Ueli!
Er war wohl der Beste,
mit dem ich je geklettert bin -
aber er war nicht
sehr erfahren darin,
wie man die Risse hier klettert.
Wir kletterten die Nose
ein paar Mal.
Und ich dachte:
"Mein Gott, wir werden sterben."
Er sicherte kaum, kletterte schnell,
aber nicht solid, und ich dachte:
"Das wird ein Desaster."
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Dann stürzte er 30 m ins Seil
und war zum Glück unverletzt,
na ja, leicht angeschlagen,
aber nicht schwer.
Und ich dachte: "Gott sei Dank."
"Jetzt haben wir eine
Entschuldigung, aufzuhören."
Es gab ein paar Schürfungen,
blaue Flecken,
so gesehen ist nicht viel passiert.
Als ich stürzte, zog es Alex
6-7 m in die Höhe von meinem Sturz,
das war schön dynamisch
und nicht so ein Problem.
Das nimmst du auch in Kauf.
Er war eher bereit,
wenn's drauf ankommt,
auch mal dem Glück zu vertrauen.
Ich kann das weniger.
Wenn ich ihm zuhörte,
was er alles für Solos
und Klettereien gemacht hatte,
dachte ich manchmal:
"Das tönt aber heikel.
Du hast das wirklich gemacht?"
Dabei ist Alex Honnold heute der
Inbegriff des riskanten Kletterers.
This is my first time climbing
on sandstone in quite a long time.
Im Yosemite, wieder am El Capitan,
wagte er 2017 die schwierigste
je ohne Seil gekletterte Route.
Eine Sensation.
It's 3'200 feet of sheer granite.
It's the center
of the rock climbing universe.
Ich wurde oft gefragt:
"Willst du das wirklich tun?"
Und ich sagte: "Ja."
Ohne Seil balancierte er
1'000 m über dem Abgrund.
Im Kinofilm "Free Solo"
wird alles mit Kameras festgehalten.
Während der Filmaufnahmen
stürzt Ueli Steck ab.
Ich war schockiert,
als ich von Uelis Tod hörte.
Ich hätte nie erwartet,
dass ihm etwas passiert.
Ich brauchte lange,
das zu verarbeiten.
Für mich sind meine Vorbilder
unverletzlich.
Es ist hart zu realisieren,
dass jeder Pech haben kann.
So funktioniert Statistik.
Ich dachte: "Jemandem, der so gut
ist wie Ueli, dem stösst nichts zu."
Aber es kann halt doch jeden
treffen, egal wie gut er ist.
Dachtest du auch an dich selber?
I mean ...
Ein bisschen, aber nicht wirklich.
Aber das ist es eben: Jeder glaubt
von sich, er wäre vorsichtig.
Aber das dachte Ueli natürlich auch.
Der Mensch
braucht die Herausforderung,
braucht ein gewisses Abenteuer.
Und wenn du das nicht mehr hast,
bist du tot.
Das ist genau das Problem,
das wir haben.
Wir wissen alle nicht,
wie lange wir hier hocken werden,
wie lange wir hier
etwas machen können.
Das weiss niemand,
das ist eine Schweizer Mentalität,
das ist ein Problem,
das wir haben in der Schweiz.
Alles auf Sicherheit
und wenn was schiefgeht,
ist es die totale Katastrophe.
Aber wir müssen es akzeptieren:
es ist nichts 100 %.
Man muss bereit sein,
das Risiko einzugehen,
sich der Gefahr auszusetzen,
aber nicht zu viel,
und die ganze Mischung führt
zu einem extrem intensiven Erleben,
und das hat Suchtpotential.
Das ist nicht ein Genuss,
wenn man drin ist,
sondern am Bergsteigen
ist der Genuss meist erst nachher.
In eine schwierige Wand einsteigen
hat immer auch mit Angst zu tun,
das ist ein Abenteuer,
und ein richtiges Abenteuer ist
immer eine unangenehme Situation,
die will man bestehen
und man will eigentlich raus,
aber das Erleben drin
ist so intensiv,
und wenn man es gut macht und merkt:
"Es ist schwierig,
aber ich habe es im Griff."
Dann ist das so intensiv und gut,
dass man es immer wieder sucht.
Die Herausforderung
war Ueli Stecks Antrieb.
Seine Frau, mit der er
über viele Jahre verheiratet war,
möchte nicht vor die Kamera treten.
Sie schreibt uns:
Sie hätte nicht immer gewusst,
ob er von den schwierigen
Expeditionen zurückkehren würde.
Sie habe erlebt, wie er
mit den Höhepunkten und Tiefschlägen
in seinem Leben gewachsen sei.
Gemeinsame Erlebnisse in den Bergen
habe beiden die Kraft gegeben,
schwierige Situationen zu meistern.
Die Zeit zu Hause war für Ueli Steck
aber oft schon die Vorbereitung
für das nächste Abenteuer.
Ich persönlich habe Mühe,
auch mal zu sagen:
"Jetzt ist mal zwei Monate easy,
jetzt lasse ich es mal treiben
und gebe mir Ruhe."
Das kommt sicher auch davon, dass,
wenn ich mit Leuten rede,
z.B. wenn ich direkt
von einer Expedition zurückkomme,
eine Woche drauf einen Vortrag
habe, die zweite Frage oft ist,
was mein nächstes Projekt ist.
Auch von aussen kommt das immer.
Es ist extrem schwierig, auch
mal den Fuss vom Gas zu nehmen.
Es hat schon immer
eine gewisse Leere,
ein Ziel erreichen ist schön,
aber es geht auch hinunter.
Nach den Alpen
richtete Ueli Steck seinen Fokus
auf die hohen Berge im Himalaya.
Es ist wichtig, gut auszusehen.
Gegen dich habe ich eh keine Chance,
du trägst Jeans.
Mit ihm unterwegs
der Kanadier Don Bowie.
Ueli Steck will testen,
wie sein Körper die Höhe verträgt.
All good.
- See you guys later.
Er war bereits auf der Shishapangma.
Als nächstes wartet der Cho Oyu.
Ein Einstiegs-Achttausender für
Bergsteiger aus der ganzen Welt.
Hello.
Hallo.
Hallo, comment ça va?
How are you? Stai bene?
Ueli war hier bekannt.
Hello, Sir.
Das ist ganz anders als bei Ueli.
Er braucht für den Berg 18 Std.,
wir 18 Tage.
Hey! Lach nicht!
Das ist wirklich so.
Doch für einmal lief auch
bei Ueli Steck nicht alles rund.
Sein Körper streikt.
Trotz Magenverstimmung
gibt er nicht auf.
Er kämpft sich auf den Gipfel.
Eine neue Erfahrung für ihn.
Gehen wir wieder runter!
Was Richtiges essen.
- Ja.
Ausruhen.
Mein Kopfweh loswerden,
und seine Magenprobleme.
In einem Hotel
erholen sie sich von den Strapazen.
Wir sind in Nyalam,
um uns zu erholen für fünf Tage.
Und so sieht's hier aus.
Und das für nur 70 $ pro Tag.
Alles Essen inklusive.
Es ist wie Las Vegas.
Ciao.
Gleich ohne Lift.
- Ja, klar.
Ciao, Bruno.
- Ciao, Vater.
Hallo.
Uelis ältester Bruder Rene
wohnt mit seiner Familie in Langnau
im Emmental.
Auch er ist kein Bergsteiger.
Mir kommt er immer in den Sinn,
wenn ich bestimmte Situationen habe,
z.B. wenn ich sein Velo benutze,
jeden Tag, wenn ich das hervornehme
kommt mir das in den Sinn:
"Oh das ist von Ueli,
da ist ein Stück vom Sattel weg, da
hat's ihn auf den Bauch geworfen."
Für mich ist er nach wie vor
sehr präsent.
Spielte es für Ueli eine Rolle,
der Jüngste zu sein?
Ja, definitiv.
Er kam unter die Räder.
Wir zwei waren älter
und gaben uns auf den Grind,
dem Kleinen durften wir nicht,
darum ist er auch immer
mitgeschleppt worden.
Er ist zäh aufgewachsen,
würde ich mal sagen.
Nicht, dass sie ihn geplagt hätten,
Ueli wollte es, er wollte
schon immer gleichwertig sein.
Er hat sich immer dermassen
auf ein Ziel fokussiert
und war glücklich,
wenn er es erreichte, egal, was.
Also ... Insbesondere ...
Auch beim Velofahren,
das war nicht sein Ding,
aber er hatte eine Riesenfreude,
wenn wir eine Tour gemacht
haben und angekommen sind.
Als Ueli Steck 2015
alle 4'000er der Alpen
ohne Auto und Bahnen zurücklegte,
waren die Brüder
für einmal gemeinsam unterwegs.
Ueli wie immer voraus.
Wir probieren es schon immer
auf die Spitze zu treiben.
Eben: Mit dem Velo runterfahren.
Wir probieren schon,
ob es noch was verträgt.
Das hat auch was mit Ehrgeiz zu tun.
Jetzt erhöhen wir für morgen
die Sicherheit.
Sie haben Angst, dass ich den Pneu
verliere, wenn ich runterfahre.
Aber ich fahre ja nie schnell.
Wir wissen unterdessen,
wie er runterfährt.
Deshalb leimen wir den Pneu noch an.
Wenn wir zusammen waren,
redeten wir über alles andere,
nicht über das Bergesteigen,
aber wir haben es auch verfolgt
und waren stolz,
auf das was er gemacht hat.
Aber nicht, dass wir jeden Tag
anrufen mussten
und fragen, was er gerade machte.
2011 versuchte sich Ueli Steck am
höchsten Berg, dem Mount Everest.
Von Tibet aus,
direkt nach dem Cho Oyu.
Weisst du was?
Wir haben eine Heizung
in unserem Zelt.
Wieder mit dabei:
der Kanadier Don Bowie.
Wie am Cho Oyu
ist er derjenige, der filmt.
Sie sind ohne Sauerstoff unterwegs.
Im Gegensatz
zu fast allen anderen am Berg.
Alle anderen Teams hier oben
in diesem Camp
haben ständig diese Atemmasken auf
wegen des Sauerstoffs.
Sie sehen aus wie die "Star Wars"-
Figur Darth Vader.
Wir kommen uns hier oben vor,
als wäre rund um uns
eine Bombe losgegangen.
Den Gipfel auf 8'848 m
erreichten sie nicht.
Ueli Steck
kehrte nur 100 m vor dem Ziel um.
Er spürte wegen der Kälte
seine Füsse nicht mehr.
Das ist ein entscheidender Punkt,
auch zu akzeptieren,
dass man scheitert, und sich dann
aber nicht kaputt macht.
Das ist im Training immer wieder so,
dass man scheitert,
und mit dem musst du umgehen können.
Und das ist genau dort,
wo viele Leute scheitern im Leben.
Sie haben nicht den Mut,
etwas zu probieren.
Ein Jahr später.
6'400 m Everest. Ich bin zusammen
mit Tenji gestern hochgekommen,
unsere Idee ist South Col, aber es
hat etwas Probleme mit Steinschlag.
Es ist eisig,
die Verhältnisse sind nicht ideal.
Aber das wird dann schon noch gehen.
Wieder ist er praktisch
der einzige ohne Sauerstoff.
Sein Partner Tenji war früher Sherpa.
Heute ist er selber Bergsteiger.
Ueli Steck war sein Mentor.
War ein langer Tag heute, Tenji.
- Ja, zu lange.
Es ist wirklich windig.
- Ja, aber nicht kalt.
Nein.
Käse und Brot und Salami,
sogar auf 8'000 m Höhe,
das ist einfach das Beste.
Sogar Tenji schmeckt's.
Ja, ja.
Das muss man ganz klar sehen,
Den Mount Everest ohne Sauerstoff
ist eine Riesenherausforderung.
Das ist knüppelhart.
Es geht recht gut bis 8'500 m
und dann wird es ziemlich streng,
da machst du nur noch
drei bis vier Schritte,
dann musst du anhalten und denkst,
so kommst du nie auf den Gipfel.
Doch diesmal schaffte er es.
Danach wollte Ueli Steck
schwierigere Wände besteigen.
Ihm war immer bewusst,
wie gefährlich es ist.
Mit Bergsteiger-Kollegen
spricht er im Everest-Basecamp
über seine Ängste.
Diese Privataufnahmen von Don Bowie
zeigen eine Seite,
die er normalerweise in der
Öffentlichkeit nicht preis gab.
Du musst aufpassen,
dass du nicht immer mehr willst.
Gut, du fängst jetzt auch an,
mehr nachzudenken.
Nein,
aber das habe ich immer gemacht.
Ja, aber mehr nachdenken,
was noch geht und was nicht.
Und du hast auch eine Frau daheim,
und hast sie gern.
Es geht nicht um das,
es geht auch um die eigene Haut.
Du exponierst dich extrem,
Speed-Ascents machen
oder einfach so loslaufen
an der Shishapangma,
da gehst du ein anderes Risiko ein
als hier am Everest.
Und je mehr du machst,
irgendwann ...
Schau dir die Geschichte
des Bergsteigens an:
Die starken Franzosen,
da ist jeder tot ausser Profit.
Der hat gesagt: "Ich habe genug,
ich bin jetzt Bergführer."
Ich muss das Gleiche machen.
Einen Schnitt für mich selber machen
und sagen: "Es ist vorbei."
"Ich habe meinen Zenit erreicht."
Wenn ich an den Everest will
für mich selber,
oder den K2 besteigen will
für mich, ist es gut.
Über seine Ängste, zu weit zu gehen,
das Limit zu überschreiten,
hat er mit seiner Familie
nie gesprochen.
Ich denke, er hat bewusst separiert,
wem er was erzählt.
Damit man sich keine Sorgen macht.
Ich glaube,
er konnte gut damit umgehen,
wem er was erzählt.
Ich habe gewusst,
dass er Risikomanagement macht.
Er hat mir auch mal gesagt:
"Schau,
ich erzähle dir möglichst wenig."
Ich habe das so akzeptiert,
wusste aber genau,
dass er mit dem umgehen kann
bzw. umgehen muss.
Er wollte damit auch bezwecken,
dass er unsere Eltern
nicht belastet.
Er wollte niemanden belasten
ausser sich selbst.
Das war immer sein Credo.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir können uns
das gar nicht vorstellen,
wir waren gar nie
in solchen Situationen.
Da besteht die Schwierigkeit,
das fassbar zu machen,
das geht nicht nur uns so,
sondern den meisten Leuten.
Wir wissen gar nicht, was das
bedeutet hat, was er gemacht hat.
* Monotoner Sprechgesang *
In Namche Bazar reist
David Göttler jetzt zum Everest.
Ich gehe nach Tangboche, Chukung
Everest Basecamp, dann Everest.
So, jetzt geht es los.
Bis dann, ciao.
Rennend, so wie er es früher
mit Ueli gemacht hat.
* Eindringliche Hang-Klänge *
Ich muss noch kurz ...
Du musst schauen wegen dem Benzin.
Maurizio Folini und Robert Bösch sind
ebenfalls Richtung Everest unterwegs.
Nicht zum Bergsteigen,
sondern zum Fotografieren.
Jetzt bin ich
im Kloster Tengpoche angelangt,
wo Ueli damals eingeäschert wurde.
Robert Bösch war
bei der Bestattung von Ueli dabei.
Auch die Eltern
waren damals nach Nepal gereist.
Die Brüder tauchten ein Jahr später
in Uelis Welt ein.
(Bruno) Du merkst einfach wieder,
was wichtig ist im Leben.
Sind wir ehrlich: Jeden
kann es treffen, einfach zu sterben.
Ich spüre Ueli jetzt viel mehr ...
... als wenn ich das nur von seinen
Schilderungen gehört hätte.
Das Zwischenmenschliche,
warum er so eine grosse Meinung
hatte von dem Land ...
... habe ich erst begriffen,
als ich dort war.
Und das kann ich jetzt
nachvollziehen.
Ich finde es auch gut,
dass sie hingegangen sind,
das Land gesehen haben, wie wir.
Einfach ... Uelis zweite Heimat.
Ueli Stecks Vertrauen in die Menschen
in seiner zweiten Heimat
wurde 2013 erschüttert.
Er war unterwegs an den Everest,
mit dem Italiener Simone Moro.
Schon damals plante er,
die beiden 8'000er
Everest und Lhotse zu verbinden.
Am Berg
kamen sie Sherpas in die Quere,
die Fixseile
für zahlende Klienten einrichteten.
Der Italiener beleidigte die Sherpas.
Das Ganze
eskalierte im Lager weiter unten.
80 Sherpas umringten die Zelte,
wollten Genugtuung.
Ueli Steck sass mitten im Tumult.
So grosse Steine
haben sie ins Zelt geworfen.
Wenn solche Steine geworfen werden
und dich einer trifft ...
Wir müssen nicht diskutieren,
was da passiert.
Es war eine sehr ...
... schlimme Situation,
die ausser Kontrolle geriet.
Die Sherpas wollten nur noch eines:
Blut sehen.
Sie sagten ... sie bringen uns um.
Das war die Situation.
Für mich war das perfid:
Ich dachte mir:
"Ich habe so viele Berge bestiegen."
"Ich ging in meinem Leben
so viel Risiko ein,
und immer ging es gut aus."
"Und jetzt werde ich
im Lager 2 am Everest
von einer Horde Sherpas umgebracht."
Mit der Todesgefahr am Berg
konnte er umgehen,
nicht aber mit dieser lebensbedroh-
lichen Situation durch Menschen,
mit denen er
zusammengearbeitet hatte.
Die zwischenmenschliche Geschichte
mit den Sherpas hat ihn beschäftigt.
Er ist ein guter Mensch,
denkt immer, er macht es richtig,
versucht, das Richtige zu tun,
und hilft, wo er kann.
Und dass diese Einstellung
einfach zusammengefallen ist,
das hat ihn extrem beschäftigt.
Das war der Tiefpunkt
in seinem Wirken.
Ja, ich denke schon.
- Ja.
Er brauchte lange,
um dieses Trauma zu verarbeiten.
Er zog sich zurück
und trainierte nur noch.
Er wollte mit der Aussenwelt
lange nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Jetzt sind wir hier oben.
Das war auch immer eine
supercoole Trainingsstrecke von uns.
Von Ueli und mir.
Hier ist man einfach
im Herzen der grossen Himalayaberge.
Das ist cool.
Ich muss viel an ihn denken,
wenn ich alleine unterwegs bin.
Aber das ist auch schön.
David Göttler
versucht es alleine auf den Everest.
Er ist vermutlich der Einzige ohne
Sauerstoff in der Menge am Berg.
Er trägt nur eine Kältemaske.
Es ist so voll, dass er es
nicht auf den Gipfel schafft.
Ohne Sauerstoff
hat er weniger Reserven
und muss auf über 8'000 m umkehren.
Ihm wird der Kommerz am Everest
zum Verhängnis.
Die letzte Nacht
war auch nicht so prickelnd,
weil ich auf den Schlafsack
verzichtet habe,
in Ueli Stecks Manier.
Aber es war ganz schön kalt,
deswegen gehe ich am Nachmittag
noch hinunter ins Lager 2.
So wie Ueli mal gesagt hat:
"Don't epic up there."
Das ist mir immer hängen geblieben.
Dass man da oben schauen muss,
dass man keinen Schmarren macht.
An den hohen Bergen
kann ein Zögern, der kleinste Fehler
zur Katastrophe führen.
Dessen war sich Ueli Steck bewusst.
Vor 20 Jahren,
als ich ihn kennengelernt habe,
wurde er step by step zu diesem
aussergewöhnlich guten Bergsteiger.
Bei ihm sind die drei, vier
Fähigkeiten zusammengekommen,
die es braucht,
um so etwas zu machen.
Sehr grosses technisches Können,
Erfahrung an den hohen Bergen,
grosse mentale Stärke
und dann noch die Ausdauerkraft.
Was es heisst,
sich an hohen Bergen zu exponieren,
erlebte Ueli Steck an der Annapurna.
Einer der gefährlichsten
Achttausender.
Schon 2007
reizte ihn die schwierige Südwand.
Mit dabei: Robert Bösch.
Mit so viel Schnee
steigst du dann nicht mehr ab,
das ist nicht mehr lustig.
Hier hat man das Gefühl,
dass es nicht so schlimm ist,
aber oben in der Wand
kommen langsam die Lawinen.
Wenn du Glück hast, ist das
Biwak an einer sicheren Stelle,
aber du kannst
weder rückwärts noch vorwärts.
Die Route stünde
für einen neuen Schwierigkeitsgrad
im Himalayabergsteigen.
Steck will sie alleine,
ohne fremde Hilfe versuchen.
Robert Bösch
begleitet ihn zum Wandfuss.
Viel Glück.
- Danke, kann ich brauchen.
Doch kaum losgeklettert,
stürzt er ab.
* Heftiges Atmen *
Verdammte Spalte.
Jetzt kann ich
nur noch der Spur nach.
Ein Stein hat ihn getroffen,
er erinnert sich an nichts.
Trottel.
Unten trifft er Robert Bösch.
Sorry, tut mir leid.
- Das muss dir nicht leid tun.
Ich habe die Pickel genommen,
aber ...
Ich weiss nicht, wie weit.
Dann hat es dich wahrscheinlich
den ganzen Weg runter geworfen.
Ja, ich war unten,
das Fähnchen war nicht weit.
Das waren wahrscheinlich 200 m.
Bist du weit über den Bergschrund?
Ich weiss nicht.
Das war ein gewaltiger Stein,
darum hast du auch
das Bewusstsein verloren.
Ich hatte mal so einen,
an einem Bergschrund.
Wenn er über den Schnee kommt,
hörst du nichts.
Es macht bumm
und du weiss nicht, was passiert.
So viel Angst wie dort oben
hatte ich noch nie.
Das war Horror.
Nur ein Jahr später
versucht er es erneut.
Diesmal zu zweit.
Dann ein Hilferuf.
* Funkruf *
Der Spanier Inaki Ochoa
ist höhenkrank.
Ueli Steck
eilt ihm mit Medikamenten zuhilfe.
Ohne richtige Ausrüstung,
die schon in einem anderen Lager ist.
Nach zwei Tagen erreicht er ihn.
Dem Spanier geht es schlecht.
Er bleibt bei ihm im Zelt -
bis dieser stirbt.
Um jemand anderem zu helfen, erreicht
Ueli Steck sein Ziel wieder nicht.
Jahre vergehen, bis es Ueli Steck
zum dritten Mal versucht.
Einem französischen Kamerateam
erklärt er, was ihn antreibt.
Nach dem zweiten Versuch
habe ich zuerst gedacht:
"Ich gehe nicht zurück.
Das ist nicht mein Berg."
Erst jetzt, nach fünf Jahren,
bin ich wieder hier.
Du beginnst nachzudenken,
es lässt dich nicht los.
Ich habe es nie richtig versucht.
Ich hatte nie richtig die Chance,
es wirklich zu versuchen.
Wieder mit dabei:
der Kanadier Don Bowie.
Maybe on top of those rocks there.
Die Route an der Annapurna
geht 2'600 m die Südwand hoch.
Über einen schwierigen Felsriegel.
Bis hinauf auf den Gipfel
auf 8'091 m Höhe.
Die Verhältnisse
scheinen dieses Jahr perfekt.
Doch dann ein Dämpfer.
Ich bin um 3 Uhr aufgewacht,
mit Schmerzen im Hals.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich
nach Nepal komme, werde ich krank.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es der Staub in Kathmandu ist.
Meine Lungen sind langsam anfällig.
Ueli Steck will unbedingt hinauf.
Grosse Berge
können Angst machen und lähmen.
Auch Ueli Steck kennt diese Angst,
aber er will sich nicht
einschüchtern lassen.
You see those black points
in the middle?
Wir müssen es versuchen.
Ja, ich verstehe das.
Ich will auch.
Wenn wir zu lange warten,
haben wir nur eine Nacht.
Ich will wieder unten sein,
wenn das Wetter umschlägt.
Am Tag, an dem der Sturm angesagt
ist, bin ich wieder hier.
Der Kanadier Don Bowie
ist gesundheitlich wieder fit
und die beiden brechen auf.
Doch als es losgeht, sagt Don Bowie
plötzlich, er komme nicht mit.
Ehrlich gesagt: Ich habe da oben
kein gutes Gefühl gehabt.
Es ist eine schwierige Wand.
Ueli ist einer der besten,
wenn nicht
der beste Bergsteiger der Welt.
Ich bin einfach nicht so gut wie er.
Das Gelände war mir zu schwierig.
Und dann hatten wir auch noch
ziemlich Steinschlag,
als wir letztes Mal oben war.
Ich kam mir so allein vor.
Da bin ich halt einfach losgegangen.
Ich gehe hoch zum oberen Lager,
schaue, wie die Bedingungen sind.
See you.
Keine Sorge, ich melde mich.
Obwohl er sich alleingelassen fühlt,
gibt er nicht auf.
Er ist allein in der grossen Wand.
Es hat viel Wind
und gefährliche Schneelawinen.
Und er stürzt deswegen fast ab.
Ich konnte mich nur noch
an den Pickeln festhalten,
dann hat es gedrückt und gedrückt.
Irgendwann hörte es auf.
Ich bin fast runtergefallen,
habe nur so gezittert.
In dem Moment ist bei mir
ein Schalter umgekippt.
Am Anfang war alles easy.
Aber dort habe ich realisiert:
"Du bist allein
in einer riesigen Wand
und vielleicht
kommst du nie mehr nach Hause."
Ich war wirklich völlig ausgesetzt.
Dann habe ich es einfach akzeptiert:
"Dann kommst du halt
nicht mehr nach Hause."
Er hat doch gesagt,
er nehme den warmen Schlafsack mit.
Ich wusste, er meint es ernst,
weil er sein Telefon nicht
vom Basecamp hochgebracht hat.
Seine Kollegen unten im Lager
haben keine Ahnung,
was sich oben am Berg abspielt.
Wir müssen abwarten.
- Bis zum Morgen.
Vielleicht sehen wir seine Lampe.
Oder er kommt plötzlich
in unser Zelt, mitten in der Nacht.
Ueli Steck
ist oben in seiner eigenen Welt.
Er wartet in einer Gletscherspalte,
bis sich der Wind legt,
klettert weiter und kommt
in der Nacht auf den Gipfel.
Die Verhältnisse
müssen sehr gut gewesen sein,
der Fels muss mit einer Eis-Schnee-
schicht verkleistert gewesen sein,
sodass die Eisgeräte gut hielten.
Darum hat er sich entschlossen,
das durchzuziehen.
Als ich auf dem Gipfel war,
war ich gar nicht sicher,
ob ich wirklich oben war.
Es war dunkel.
Dann ist mir plötzlich aufgegangen:
"Oh mein Gott."
"Ich bin hier auf 8'000 m oben,
unter mir sind 2'600 m."
Und du willst nur noch runter,
nach Hause.
Die Freunde unten bangen.
Am Morgen taucht er wieder auf.
Ganze 28 Std. lang
ist er unterwegs gewesen.
Okay, rolling.
Das geht mir zu schnell.
Ich bin todmüde.
Habe seit mehr als 24 Std.
nicht geschlafen.
War fast die ganze Zeit in Bewegung.
Es waren wirklich
wahnsinnig gute Bedingungen.
Das hatte ich auch
an der Shishapangma.
Das hast du nur einmal im Leben
und dann musst du einfach gehen.
Du kommst wie
von einem anderen Planeten zurück.
Ich konnte meinen Kollegen
nicht erklären,
was ich da oben erlebt habe.
Ueli Steck hat damit eine neue
Dimension im Bergsteigen aufgezeigt.
So schnell, völlig allein,
das hatte noch nie jemand geschafft.
Ich war bereit, sehr weit zu gehen,
sogar zu sterben.
Das hatte ich noch nie.
Nur so kannst du
wahrscheinlich so etwas machen.
Sonst machst du das nicht
in diesem Stil.
Für diesen Berg war er bereit,
sein Leben zu lassen.
Die Tragik der Geschichte:
Er hatte keinen Beweis dafür,
dass er tatsächlich oben war.
Das muss ein unglaublich
brutaler Moment gewesen sein,
als er vom Gipfel runterkam.
Er hat keinen Gedanken
daran verschwendet.
Er kommt zurück in die Sicherheit,
er hat es überlebt,
der ganze Druck, der sich bei ihm
über Jahre aufgebaut hat,
weil er dieses Projekt
über Jahre verfolgt hat.
Das ist alles weg, und dann
kommt relativ schnell die Frage:
"Kannst du es beweisen?"
Dann muss ihm sofort klar gewesen
sein, er kann es nicht beweisen.
Niemand hat ihn von unten gesehen.
Er hatte keine Kamera mehr,
und oben war es dunkel.
Und er hatte auch nicht
eine GPS-Uhr eingestellt.
Er wusste in dem Moment,
er wird es nie beweisen können.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Ueli Steck wurde als Lügner betitelt.
Selbst gute Freunde
glaubten ihm nicht.
Das ist schon heftig,
das geht einem nahe.
Und ich glaube ...
... er hat vor- und nachher nie so
viel Zeit bei uns im Büro verbracht.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass es nicht gut ist.
Ich hatte nicht das Gefühl,
dass er sich in seinem Leben
je mit etwas aufspielen wollte.
(Lisabeth)
Nein, das war nicht sein Ding.
Ihm nicht zu glauben -
das war für ihn
fast nicht nachvollziehbar.
Denn er war
ein so gutgläubiger Mensch,
dass das für ihn
einfach nicht vorstellbar war,
dass ihm das jemand nicht glaubt.
Der Höhepunkt war auch ein Tiefpunkt.
Er spürte, dass es Zeit war,
mit dem Extrembergsteigen aufzuhören.
Bei einem seiner Sponsoren
unterschrieb er für eine
neue Karriere als Produktdesigner.
2017 wollte er aber noch
ein letztes grosses Projekt wagen.
Er war 40 Jahre alt.
So fit wie noch nie.
Erneut sein Plan: die Verbindung
der 8'000er Everest und Lhotse.
Ohne Sauerstoff. Das hatte noch nie
ein Mensch geschafft.
* Pulsierende, surrende Klänge,
schweres Atmen *
Es ist ein Ausdauerproblem.
Irgendwann hat man keine Kraft mehr,
dann muss man wieder runter.
Eigentlich
hat man überall einen Exit.
Von daher
ist es kein One-Way-Ticket.
So habe ich für mich das Gefühl,
es ist ein vertretbares Risiko.
Ich habe das Projekt
bewusst gewählt.
Ich wusste, wenn ich mich weiter auf
dem Niveau der letzten Jahre bewege,
knallt es irgendwann
und geht nicht gut aus.
Mit diesem Projekt habe ich
für mich eine sportliche Challenge,
aber wirklich nur
eine sportliche Challenge -
entweder schaffe ich es oder nicht,
es ist keine Harakiri-Aktion.
Das Projekt würde er zusammen mit
seinem Freund Tenji Sherpa angehen,
mit dem er 2012 schon am Everest war.
Hoch auf den Everest, dann über die
Normalroute absteigen in den Südcol.
Dort traversieren wir über ein Band
in die Normalroute
vom Lhotse auf den Gipfel.
Wenn wir mal dort sind,
geht es direkt nach unten
ins Western Cwm und ins Lager 2.
Er hat gesagt, er käme wohl
zum letzten Mal hierher.
Und das letzte Mal, dass er
am Everest etwas Extremes mache.
Ich denke, er machte sich
wahrscheinlich schon Gedanken,
andere Dinge zu machen
und langsam runterzufahren.
Das ist auch normal.
* Eindringliche Streicherklänge *
Kurz vor seiner Abreise ging er
mit dem Vater noch auf eine Skitour.
Am Sonntag bevor er nach Nepal ging,
kam er und sagte:
"Vater, wir gehen diese Woche
zusammen über die Lötschenlücke."
Er hat noch Termine abgesagt
und alles.
Ich habe beim Hochgehen auf der Bahn
ein ungutes Gefühl gehabt.
Das hatte es zuvor nie gegeben ...
... dass wir etwas
so spontan machten.
Ich musste etwas leiden,
und das Letzte rausholen,
aber es hat sich gelohnt.
(Lisabeth) Das ist die letzte
Erinnerung, das vergisst du nie.
Die letzten Aufnahmen von Ueli Steck
im Everest-Basecamp.
Drei Jahre ist es nun her,
dass ihn seine Freunde Robert Bösch
und Maurizio Folini
im Everest-Basecamp treffen wollten.
Der Zufall will es,
dass auch Tenji Sherpa hier oben ist,
mit dem Ueli Steck eigentlich nach
dem Nuptse auf den Everest wollte.
Er war wie mein Bruder.
Es war eine der schwierigsten Zeiten
in meinem Leben.
Ich werde Ueli nie vergessen.
Auch nicht,
was ich von ihm gelernt habe.
(Robert) Ich glaube, er hatte sich
gefreut, auf diesen Berg zu kommen.
Und ich meine,
das war Uelis Welt -
nicht der Rummel hier im Basecamp,
im Gegenteil.
Aber das, was da oben ist,
die Intensität,
die man beim Bergsteigen erlebt.
Ich glaube, das ist seine Welt,
dafür hat er trainiert
und dafür hat er gelebt.
Eigentlich wollte Ueli Steck auf
dem normalen Weg Richtung Everest,
um sich an die Höhe zu gewöhnen.
Doch dann lockte ihn doch wieder
die Herausforderung: der Nuptse.
Möglicherweise hatte er diesen Berg
als dritten nach Everest und Lhotse
ins Auge gefasst.
Etwa um 9 Uhr geschah der Unfall.
Da war er schon nah am Gipfel.
Es lief ihm mit Sicherheit sehr gut.
Es gibt nichts Besseres
für einen Bergsteiger als zu merken:
"Ich bin bereit. Es ist schwierig,
aber ich habe es im Griff."
"Ich komme gut vorwärts."
Deshalb glaube ich -
was auch immer passiert ist -,
dass Ueli bis zu diesem Moment
ein glücklicher Mensch war.
(Lisabeth) Für uns war gut,
dass man ihn gefunden hat.
Und wir konnten Abschied nehmen.
Wir mussten uns keine Gedanken
machen, wann man ihn wohl findet,
wann wir hinreisen müssen,
um zu bestätigen, dass er es ist.
Und man kann sagen,
dass es seine zweite Heimat war.
Heute erinnert im Bergsteigerfriedhof
am Everest eine Stupa an Ueli Steck.
An seinen Drang, Neues zu wagen,
sich selber zu übertreffen.
In Tibet heisst ein Sprichwort:
"Lieber einen Tag als Tiger,
als 1'000 Tage lang ein Schaf."
* Eindringliche Streicherklänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
L. Thomann, A. Duttweiler,
M. Krähenbühl, L. Zbinde